für 216 s kids ich bitte es geldberg mit
neuer frisur und heute um 18 uhr gibt es
meinen ersten live stream an allerersten
mit dabei wird dieser dieser männliche
sein und neben max wird und gleich noch
ob apple dabei seien diese bock hätte
denn es bleibe dabei sein mag es wird
dabei sein
währen wird eventuell reinschauen und es
wird richtig richtig geil wenn glaube
ich ziemlich lustige zeit haben zusammen
haben wenn ihr vorbeischaut und um dabei
zu sein müsst ihr auftritt punkt ev /
krankhafter acht asse müsst ihr auftritt
streitkräfte gehen
ich bitte den link jetzt ein und das
müsste sie das noch nicht abonniert hat
abonniert unbedingt diesen channel ist
also ein bisschen schwierig jetzt jetzt
auf die aussage zu konzentrieren aber
möchte bitte abonniert in channel dann
damit wir da zusammen ein bisschen
stellen kann
ich will jetzt einfach auf maxis channel
machen weil ich keinen eigenen hat und
würde ich sagen wie gesagt
denn auch in der beschreibung einfach
den link klicken abonnieren um 18 uhr
gehts los wir sehen uns dann haut rein
und schaut ja und vielen vielen dank an
den special effects